Good, let's get to pitching. Pitching is around the transverse axis — the transverse axis is this axis through the wing; we have the transverse axis, we have the longitudinal axis, and we have the vertical axis.
The motion around the transverse axis is called pitching. It's important for when we for example fly into a thermal — there the wing pitches up on us — we have to make sure we bring the wing back over us,
or on the way out of the thermal the wing pitches forward and we may have to bring it back over our head with brakes.
And that's why this manoeuvre is so important to train, that you get to know this motion, properly build up the wing oscillation — even quite extreme oscillations — and pull it back over yourself again with the brake from that strong oscillation.
That's a very good pilot, who masters that.
When pitching, always pay attention that we're not too early and not too fast with the brake.
I'll demonstrate it for you in a moment, but those are the most common sources of error: you simply try to pull too fast and too deep to build up the pitch strongly.
It's more about the timing of the brake than the intensity.
With bigger pendulums we always have to pull more brake — that's logical, clear, no way around it.
But at the start what's decisive is that we brake slowly and when we begin braking again the next time.
OK, so pitching also means that we try with the body to seek a bit of contact with the harness — that is, push the knees apart a bit, look at the wing and look at the flight direction.
So we don't just stare stubbornly at the wing, but a bit in alternating glances.
All clear, it's going in this direction or where is the wing actually going.
Good, for pitching I recommend not wrapping the brakes, but keeping the brakes at the loop in the hand, because we can fully release the wing by releasing the brakes, which is often not the case with the rubbing-strap wrap.
OK, good, then I say on the radio, pull, pull, pull, pull, and each time you pull, you pull about three to four centimetres.
That means the first 15, 20 centimetres we pull quite slowly.
I say on the radio, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, hands up.
Did you see that? So really start slowly, but hands up as fast as you can.
So pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, hands up, bang, pow, right?
So really briskly up, try maybe even to work a bit along the riser when braking.
So that you don't go outward with the brake, but really have a nice guidance parallel to the riser.
OK, then wait. Very important, wait.
Specifically, by braking, you swing forward.
Now we wait until the wing is at the dead point behind, and then we let the brakes go.
That means the wing accelerates full bar.
And now we have to wait until we've swung through underneath the wing again.
When we accelerate the wing, we then have to brake the wing through again.
If we brake on the downward motion, we take away all the energy we've just built up.
And that's why it's so important that we wait, so we take all the energy, all the speed with us and swing past under the wing.
That means we're like on a swing, already slightly in the upward motion again.
And only then does the brake come another time.
Now, on the second or also the third time, simply a bit deeper.
That means brake, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, even deeper.
Hands up, bang, right?
We can pull a bit deeper, no problem, because we have the speed.
When the pitch angle is right, I'll say to you, OK, now brake one more time.
So do it once more.
That means you swing through at the bottom.
Are a bit in the climbing phase.
Then again pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, hands up.
And now it's like this, we now only let the wing come forward.
Let's say 45 to 60 degrees.
And then we want to stop it there in front.
That means with both brakes, bang, briefly stop.
So let the wing go from back there forward again.
And stop it here in front.
And we've already swung underneath.
Very important manoeuvre.
You also have to approach it slowly.
I'll guide you closer and closer to it.
It doesn't have to be perfect at the start.
But pay attention that you respond to my commands.
That means when I say, pull, pull, pull, pull, the brake, pull on it.
I say, hands up, really symmetrically.
And whip the hands up.
And then I'll say on the radio, wait.
Then you really have to wait until you've swung past the wing.
And at the dead point on the way up.
And then only does the command from me come, brake, pull, pull, pull, pull, hands up.
When braking always pay attention that we start symmetrically.
If you pull right a bit earlier than left, then we make a small right turn.
Or if when releasing you bring the right hand a bit earlier than the left.
Or the other way around.
Then we also make a turn to one side.
And that wouldn't be the goal.
Now, that's a source of error that can happen with pitching.
That's why I ask you to simply approach it somewhat more slowly at the start.
I'll tell you, pull a bit more or a bit deeper.
If you pull too fast, too fast and too deep at the start, then you can stall the wing.
What's important is, I see it from below.
I'll then say, hands up.
Really keep the hands up.
Let the wing fly.
If we've pulled the wing too far into the stall, so to speak — really tipped back a bit —
then it can be that the wing accelerates forward and collapses at the front.
We allow that.
We simply keep the hands up.
We perhaps react only to the collapse.
That means if the wing stays hung up on one side, then we sort it out by direction control.
So stabilise direction.
But that then comes from me.
Pull the left brake or the right brake.
Depending on what the situation is.
As a rule the wing recovers by itself without us having to do anything.
That's why it's important, once we've actually stalled the wing, keep the hands up.
Keep up.
Wait until the wing has recovered from the whole thing.
If we somehow have a collapse, line-over, whatever — then we react to that.